hi I'm Sean Cannon and I play Sergio
Veneto in limelight
I was actually vacationing at Palm
Springs with my wife just having a good
time on a Sunday afternoon and I got a
call from my agent who said that I had
been offered this part and you know it's
it's not very often that you don't have
to audition for a part and I said great
let's read the script see see you know
what's going on and you know I liked it
the character appealed to me and Here I
am Sergio is a very Machiavellian film
producer he he seems like he's a real
decent guy initially very charismatic
and in reality he's a very self-serving
you know he's kind of a cliche in a lot
of ways he's kind of a cliche of all the
the negativity that you hear about sort
of the dark side of the business I guess
I came to LA May 20th 1987 for a
specificity it's absolutely nothing like
I thought it would be I mean you know I
think that you know so funny I was
talking to my wife
and I was talking to another actor the
other day and I said you know be the
amount of arrogance that you have to
have to say I'm gonna go to Hollywood
and be an actor that I'm interesting
enough for people who you know most
likely pay to watch is kind of off the
Richter scale but you also have to have
that level of I guess belief in yourself
to to make the journey to do this it
doesn't come with a playbook for me it
has been like most actors ups and downs
you know you have some feast and famine
hopefully it's a little more feast and
famine and I've been very fortunate in
that way that you know I've been able to
do this for the better part of my adult
life and not have to get a real job but
no it's it's probably nothing like I
imagined it would be
when I was getting on the plane some 30
years ago to come out here almost 30
years ago anyway I started studying
right away when I came out here I
started studying more in London and it
was very fortunate to be able to study
with a teacher that Calibre's I'm a huge
proponent of studying acting whether you
know you're fortunate enough to do a
program like you know Juilliard or
Carnac Carnegie Mellon errata or
something like that I didn't do that I
was a political science major which I
also feel gave me certain insights that
I might not have might not have if I had
just a traditional acting background
that being said studying is very
important but I think being a
self-starter and not you know trying to
create your own opportunities is really
important I mean that's that's probably
the single biggest piece of advice I get
of young actors you know there's so many
mediums available now is social
networking and you know with the
internet to create your own media
business card and you know go out and
produce something with your friends you
know put it on YouTube do something
that's gonna show you that you can then
send out and at least say hey take a
look at me you know a lot of that wasn't
available to me when I started out in
kind of the you know the late eighties
so I think to answer your question to
come full circle yeah it's important to
study but you don't want to be a
lifelong student without jumping into
the pool and actually getting into the
you know the professional aspect I mean
it's called show business there's you
know there's a thing that we used to
always say is that there's there's
probably a lot of waiters out there that
are maybe more accomplished better
actors in class than I am but you know
you got to get out there and and take a
swing to get into business I think it's
being able to find your happiness during
the times that you're not working you
know so much of being an actor is is
looking for work
it's an inordinate disproportionate
percentage of time that you're looking
for work as opposed to actually being on
set being employed earning money all of
that sort of stuff and it's critical
that you can find happiness in life
aside from the infrequent successes that
you know you get as an actor and it took
me a long time to learn that you know
you obviously have to find it within
yourself and then creating you know your
your support base whether it's your
family your friends around you and get
your happiness from that and then
everything else that comes into your
life with with acting is icing on the
cake people always say how difficult
psychologically it is for actors during
the times that they're not working and I
don't think until you've been an act or
an experience that you really understand
the depths of how difficult those times
can be I think you have to go through
that so that you start strategizing how
to not emotionally go through that the
next time that you have a down time you
know how to be happy during those
periods when you know you're not the guy
being called for the the part in the
film or on a TV series and I think that
it's you know the steel is tempered in
the fire sort of deal if you can if you
can make it through those tough times
and come out intact and maybe even a
little bit better it makes you that much
more interesting a person and therefore
hopefully an actor
absolutely not there was no way that I
was gonna take it no no I I came out
here and shortly thereafter I got what
at the time was probably my biggest
break which was playing the heavy in
Karate Kid 3 and I got it from an
open-call standing in line with 1,500
other people and John avildsen who had
won the Academy Award for rocky picked
me out of a line and I wound up being
cast and that really you know that
really changed the trajectory of my
career
thank you very much appreciate it